Grace: Ready?
Hannah: Not yet. Okay.
Grace; I like that I look like I'm just trying to hangout with you guys while you're making a video.
*laughter*
Hannah: Hey Maims.
Mamrie: I love this red wine, I'm glad there's only two of us splitting a bottle.
Hannah: I say, yes.
*screaming*
*bouncy noise*
Grace: Hi guys, welcome to this video!
We're here with Mamrie Hart and Hannah Hart. If you don't know, they're.... *sighs*
I thought it'd be really fun today to do a little bit of a challenge.
Mamrie/Hannah: Oooh!
Grace: A little bit of a 'which friend knows me better' challenge.
Mamrie: Mmm, I looove creating conflict!
*dramatic noises*
Hannah: Ha ha
*disturbing loop of Hannah's 'ha ha'*
Grace: It's that perfect point in the night, where we've had a couple drinks and this might end up awfully.
So hey, let's risk it, we're all gamblers here.
Mamrie: *high pitched* Do you gamble Hannah?
Hannah: No, I save my money!
Mamrie: Oh, Grace and I are f*cking massive fans.
*laughter*
Hannah: I do like the slots.
Grace: Oh okay.
Mamrie: *suggestive tone* Yeah I know you do.
Hannah: No slot shaming!
Grace: Alright get it out.
So I have ten questions for you guys, and you have some paper in front of you.
I'll ask the question, you guys write down your answer,
and then we'll see who got it right or wrong or close.
Hannah: Why does Mamrie have a Sharpie and I get a pen?
Grace: Is one better than the other?
Hannah: Yeah Sharpie, you can see it more.
Grace: Some things that aren't as seen, are more important.
Mamrie: Go on.
*cackley laughter*
Grace: Ok here we go first question:
Grace: Let me know when you're set.
Mamrie: Set.
Hannah: I'm set.
Grace: Okay Mamrie, what's your answer?
Mamrie: Ann, no 'e'.
Hannah: I said Anne 'e'.
Grace: It's Anne with an 'e'!
*party horn noise*
Mamrie: I thought it was a trick question cause I was like, "it's gotta be with an e!"
and I knew it did because I filled out something with your name in it today and-
Grace: Did you steal my identity today? Is that what you're saying? You stole my identity today?!
Grace: That's one to zero.
Mamrie: Oh motherfu-
Grace: Question number two:
*dramatic, slightly creepy music*
Grace: Yeah, cool face.
Hannah: I think I spelled this college wrong.
Grace: It does- the spelling's okay, as long as you get close.
Okay Hannah, what is your answer?
Hannah: I said Harvard.
Mamrie/Grace: *sarcastic* Woww!
Mamrie: You spelled that wrong?! No wonder you didn't get in!
Grace: Did you cross off the 'r'?
Hannah: This 'r'? Is it 'Havard'?
Mamrie: It's not 'Havard'!!
*wheezing laughter*
Grace: Wow, okay. Um, well it's also incorrect.
Hannah: Aahhurgh
Grace: But I appreciate the ass kissing, thank you.
Okay Mamrie?
Mamrie: Ramapo college, and you gave the 2015 commencement speech.
*more party horn noises*
*Grace cheers*
Mamrie: Jersey!
Grace: *laughter*
Grace: So it's one to one, here we go.
Question number three:
Mamrie: Oh f*ck
Grace: I wouldn't know this for you guys.
Hannah: New married name or her maiden name?
Grace: You know my mom's maiden name?
Hannah: Yes.
Mamrie: You know the maiden name isn't the first married name right?
Hannah: Yeah.
*laughter*
Grace: You know that, their last name is not 'Helbig'.
Mamrie, what's your answer?
Mamrie: I said; 'Mrs. Theresa, wife of Bill'.
*laughter*
Grace: Technically, not incorrect.
Hannah: I said 'Theresa Jones'.
Grace: Okay, I mean that might be her witness protection name.
Grace: Her name's 'Theresa *chipmunk noise*'
*noises of disappointment*
Hannah: Do you want them knowing?
Grace: No, I'll bleep that out.
Okay, still one to one. Next question:
Mamrie: *gasps* f*ck, f*ck!
Grace: Yeah, I forget about it sometimes too.
Mamrie: Oh no!
Grace: I can give guys a clue.
Mamrie: Please! Please, please, please.
Grace: Mythical creature.
Hannah: I'm gonna say a word that doesn't exist.
Mamrie: Creature...?
Grace: You're gonna say a word that doesn't exist?! *giggles*
Mamrie: *high pitched squeak*
Hannah: *amused splutter*
*squeak and splutter repeat*
Mamrie: Jersey!
Grace: I mean, this doesn't define our friendship, just so you guys know.
Mamrie/Hannah: Okay.
Grace: Ready?
Hannah: Yep.
Grace: Okay Hannah, what's your answer?
Hannah: Pixie?
Grace: Pixie? Okay.
Um, close. Mamrie?
Mamrie: Wilderbeast.
Grace: Also very- I mean combine those two things and you get the actual name.
Um, Phoenix, was her name.
Mamrie/Hannah: Woah! Phoenix!
Mamrie: Also a great online college!
Pixie Wilderbeast. Now that's a good stripper name!
For like a sci-fi strip club? Let's open one!
Let's open one!
Mamrie *amused 'uhhuh' noise*
*'uhhuh' noise repeats*
Hannah: Literally, I've been preparing for this moment for years.
Grace: Okay next question,
It's still one to one.
Hannah: Ah! Ahhh!
Mamrie: Okay, hold on. I have to go back in my head. Let me see.
*Vanilla Ice - 'Ice Ice Baby' intro plays*
Grace: I like watching people do math in their head.
Mamrie, what's your answer?
Mamrie: October 2011?
Grace: Incorrect.
Mamrie: *gasps*
Hannah: That's not right. That's not right
Grace: Hannah, what's your answer?
Hannah: Boom!
Grace: 2012? Is correct!
Hannah: *cheers*
*more party horn noises*
Grace: At 2012, after hurricane Sandy, I moved-
Mamrie: Do I get a point for 'Theresa, wife of Bill'?
Grace: You get half a point.
Hannah: 1.5
Grace: You get one and a half to two points, right now.
Okay, we're halfway through the game.
Hannah: Oh pffft, easy.
Mamrie: I'm bad at this stuff!
I know what it is cause her birthday is five days after mine, yo.
Hannah: Can we do a bonus question like what's your animal year?
Grace: Oh, what year was i born?
Hannah: Animal year.
Grace: Do i know-  Oh yeah, if you kno- yeah sure, you can get- um
If you know my animal year in the- what is it, Chinese Zodiac?
Hannah: Mmhmm
Grace: Then... you'll get a bonus point.
Hannah: I think it's this.
Grace: Hannah, what's your answer?
Hannah: Libra, Ox?
Mamrie:*gasps*
Grace: That's correct.
*party horn noise and cheering*
Hannah: Okay, I'll just take one point. I don't need-
Mamrie: Dammit!
Grace: But I like Mamrie's answer and I'm giving her a point-
Mamrie: Libra, Cock.
Grace: I'll give you two points for that.
*cheering*
Hannah: Do i also still get two points?
Grace: You also get two points.
So now it's what? Four to three and a half?
Grace: And this is like, the closest to not going over.
Hannah: Okay, um.
Grace: Or just closest. I don't care if you go over.
And this will hopefully change in a good way, by the time I edit this video.
Mamrie: Are we doing like, to the-
Hannah: I did all seven numbers.
Grace: I don't have all seven. Do, um-
I did four numbers.
Okay, Mamrie, what's your answer?
Mamrie: 2.974 million
Grace: Hannah?
Hannah: I put 3.25-
-0?
Grace: Ohh! Mamrie's closer!
Hannah: F*ck!
Grace: 3.023
Mamrie: *whoop!*
Hannah: Wait, look how close my first answer was!
Mamrie: I know dude! Tell that to Bob Barker, bitch!
There are rules in place.
Hannah: Look at this guys, look! This is my first- can you see-
Grace: Okay so Mamrie gets a point. That means, 4.5 to 4!
*sad piano music*
Grace: At this current moment.
Hannah: Why you writing so fast?
Grace: Whoever gets closest, you can go over. Whoever gets closest.
Mamrie: I'm guessin'
Grace: Okay Mamrie, what's your answer?
Mamrie: 122
Grace: Okay Hannah, what's your answer?
Hannah: 86?
Grace: Hannah's identically correct.
*party horns and cheering*
Grace: At this moment, 86 episodes of Not Too Deep, available.
*high pitched Grace giggles*
Grace: That's witchcraft!
Hannah: I just estimated.
Mamrie: Do you have a feed in your ear from Jack Ferry?
Grace: Now five to four and a half?
Okay, we have two more questions left.
Grace: Don't look at me!
Mamrie: Okay.
Grace: Ready?
Mamrie: Yeah, yeah.
Grace: Hannah, what's your answer?
Hannah: Three.
Grace: Okay, Mamrie, what's your answer?
Mamrie: Four.
Grace: The correct answer is 'two'.
Mamrie: Oh just your ears?
Hannah: Just your ears.
Grace: Just two in my ears- well cause this is two right?
One hole...two holes.
Mamrie: Oh no, that's four.
Grace: That's four?
Mamrie: That's how i calculated it.
Grace: That's what you were counting?
Mamrie: Yes.
Hannah: Wait, that's four!
Grace: Ohhhh!!
Mamrie: I counted holes.
Grace: Oh okay, then Mamrie's right!
*more party horns*
Grace: Now it's five and a half to five and we have one question left.
Hannah: f*ck!
Grace: Oh my God!
Last question, here we go,
who knows me better?
Mamrie: O-kay, here we go.
Hannah: Okay, I know one.
Mamrie: Done.
Hannah: And you know them all?
Mamrie: Hmm, yeah baby.
*'hmm, yeah baby' repeated*
*'yeah baby' repeated*
Grace: Hannah, what're your answers?
Hannah: Applebee's?
Grace: Correct.
Hannah: Cheesecake?
Grace: Incorrect.
Hannah: TGI Friday's?
Grace: Also incorrect.
Cheesecake was like, the epitome, i didn't get that high.
Hannah: Oh, you didn't get that good?
Mamrie: So but that- still that's one... outta three.
Grace: So you got one. Okay, so let's see if Mamrie can beat that.
Mamrie: Chili's?
Grace: Correct.
Mamrie: Houston's?
Grace: Yeah, correct.
Hannah: That's what-? What is Houston's?
Grace: It's a chain. There's two of them in New York.
Mamrie: The Hillstone group.
Mamrie: And Dave and Buster's.
Grace: That's correct!
*party horns and cheering*
*Hannah laments*
Hannah: Nooooo!
Grace: Mamrie Hart is the winner!!
Mamrie: *whoops*
Grace: I don't have any prizes for you.
Mamrie: It's fine.
Hannah: How many chain restaurants have you worked in?
Grace: I would also have accepted-
Hannah: Applebee's.
Grace: Applebee's, Chili's, Olive Garden.
Mamie/Hannah: Ohh, Olive Garden!
Mamrie: Dave and Busters was in Philly with the inmates right?
Grace: Yes.
Hannah: What?!
Grace: Yep, so many fun mem's.
Thank you guys so much for watching, I don't have a gift for you Mamrie, I should have thought of this-
Mamrie: You're a gift! The friendship is a gift!
All: Cheers!
Grace: Make sure you guys go over and check out Mamrie and Hannah's channel,
because we made a bunch of videos over there.
'A bunch' meaning, one.
Hannah: Channels.
Grace: Channels.
Grace: We made really fun videos over there, one of them-
-are you touching each other's-
Mamrie: I accidentally touched her hand, and she took it as a move!
*Ludacris - 'What's your Fantasy' plays*
Grace: Okay, we're gonna leave now, before this gets really weird. I don't know.
Hannah: Havard?
Mamrie: It's not 'Havard'!
*wheezing laughter*
Hannah: *embarrassed laugh* It's a big 'r'.
Mamrie: It's not 'HAvard'!
Hannah: It's a big 'r'! *mumbles 'Havard'*
Is it 'Har-Vard'?
Mamrie/Grace: HARVARD! *sounds like Har-verd'*
Hannah: 'Harvard'? *pronounces correctly*
Grace: Yeah, so you spelled it correctly and then you took it away.
Hannah: Okay so I spelled it correctly.
Mamrie: Oh, my God, if that ain't a metaphor!